I was cracked.
Jared again,
you might have noticed that Sasha Baron
Cohen,
the mind behind allergy Borat Bruno and
the dictator has a new show out with who
is America making Sarah Pailin publicly
complaining about being duped and Roy
more threatening to sue.
It's hard to miss.
Is it possible to sign my waterboard?
Sure.
Thank you.
Find the space that,
yeah,
but how does Cohen do it?
How does he keep getting such high
profile people to make fools of
themselves on camera?
Well,
while he may land his bare ass on m and
m space or Russell,
the occasional fat dude,
his brand of comedy is more
sophisticated than you might think.
No,
seriously.
Maybe I'm mad with this dream of
becoming a world famous artist just by
using my income.
Am I?
I think we're all mad and it all has to
do with cloud the creepiest con.
So come float with us for this wisecrack
condition on the philosophy of Sasha
Baron Cohen.
But before we get into it,
jared,
irl here and I want to give a quick
shout out to our sponsors over at better
health.
Better help is online counseling with
licensed professionals that's
accessible,
confidential,
and works around your schedule.
I tried it myself,
so stay tuned to the end to hear more
about my experience.
In the meantime,
check better help.com/wise
crack five to learn more.
And now on the Sasha in case you don't
know who Sasha Baron Cohen is,
he rose to fame in the late nineties for
his brief segments on UK tvs,
the 11 o'clock show,
which also gave rise to Ricky Gervais'.
His sketches were based around a
character initially called the Youth
Lanka.
He was dressed like a stereotypical
chaff or a British insult for obnoxious
lower class kids who had delusions of
being part of the gangster rap
lifestyle.
The limbo stains from the house.
Is it good sized truck
character transformed into what we now
know as allergy allergy started by
interviewing British establishment
figures with pompous titles who are
desperate to seem down with the kids,
but predictably this always backfires
perhaps,
or they bathed in us as milk.
She often exposed how out of touch those
politicians and academics could be.
It's much more democratic.
UC The rap scene.
Within a year,
he won the British comedy award for best
newcomer his other characters bore at,
and Bruno were also making appearances
at the time and they all seem to have
the same kind of finger on the pulse,
confrontational satire that improves
such a hit with allergy.
Sure enough,
20 years or hit movies and a major
animation franchise.
Later Cohen is back with his patented
brand of character comedy in who is
America Auggie's.
No,
they all artificial prosthetics
specially designed.
They look just like my real aunts,
but his style of pissing off suits
didn't just appear overnight.
Cohen had training from a surprising
place in the mid Nineties Cohen,
it's ended and elite clown school in
Paris called Ecole Phillipe Galley.
Yay.
All right.
It's not technically a clown school.
It's a performing art school,
but it is run by master clown,
Felipe golly eight who was a pupil of
famous,
my member formers shock McCook who
followed in the footsteps of classics
and mccloud's like Laurel and hardy,
Buster Keaton and Charlie Chaplin.
But before you start asking,
where am I?
Oversized novelty shoes,
clowns are more than just red wigs and
honky noses.
They have a pretty complicated history
that can help explain how we landed
here.
Just remember to point puppy pistols
mouth right at the middle of the bad
man.
If he has a big fat tummy pointed that
good.
Hey,
it's fine.
Way Back in 16th century Italy,
a type of traveling theater developed
called commedia Dell'arte that was
performed on the back of a wagon by
actors in masks,
which already seems creepy enough even
for clowns.
Commedia Dell'arte took the form of
sketches and Improv with an elaborate
bit of slap stick performed in the
middle by a character called the
Harlequin.
Well,
sorta like her.
The harlequin wore a checkered costume
and acted in silence mostly so the
actors didn't have to translate for the
different Italian dialects.
This section of the performance came to
be known as the pantomime.
By the 17th century.
Pantomimes were a whole show in
contained a section called the Harlequin
aid,
which introduced the character called
the clown.
The clown was created as a buffoonish
companion to the Harlequin.
Their physical comedy left a trail of
destruction behind them,
a kind of humor that we see everywhere
around us today.
They were also borish and crude
Chrisman,
Nan's boyfriend and Derek Ima was telman
then that is kind of bilingual.
How many languages does that mean him
speak and the word clown originally
meant rustic or peasant,
meaning they were used as a depiction of
the lowest class in society.
Okay,
is my neighbor symptoms.
He is barely my ass holes.
I get the window from a glass.
It wasn't good.
The window from a glass.
These broader comedy moments of Cohen's
characters certainly seem to live up to
this classical definition of a clown,
but in those examples,
the clown is the one being laughed at.
Cohen's humor is unique and that it
often turns the tables and gets the
audience laughing at say,
a Georgia state Rep.
How touch with Webex.
I'll catch you going to dropped the gun
her,
I'll check you.
Well,
there's a theatrical tradition to that
too.
One that is inextricably linked to
clowned him,
the full building off commedia,
Dell'Arte Shakespeare.
It's always can shakespeare develop the
full character in his place,
which was a mix of court,
Jester and clown,
even occasionally called them clowns and
while they were certainly comic relief,
there are other main role was to speak
truth to power.
The fool and Shakespeare tends to hang
around the important nobles and in the
process of getting the laugh,
they often unexpectedly have something
profound to say and if they can say
whatever,
no one else can,
it's because everyone discounts them as
an idiot.
Do you think president trump,
he's your friend,
do you think he might've had a golden
shower?
Would surprise me.
For example,
Shakespeare's comedy 12th night,
the character Fesa is often called a
wise fool because he sums up the play's
themes and gives an honest assessment of
the situation when the other characters
don't.
For instance,
when he's asked to sing,
instead of just performing the
shakespearian equivalent of deaths
Pasito,
he sings a song that explicitly states
the place themes of young love.
It's haste and it's follows.
Another important element of the fool is
that they're foolish just springs out
the stupidity in those around them.
In a midsummer night's dream,
the full character appropriately called
bottom,
has his head literally turned into an
ass without realizing it.
Yeah.
Shakespeare wasn't always subtle.
This is to make an ass of me.
He's then left to wander the forest
where he meets the fairy Queen Titanium
who under the influence of a love potion
falls in love with him,
asked hedanol bottom remains unaware of
his condition.
So entertains titanium is misguided
affection,
which allows the audience to literally
laughed their asses off bottom.
Just like allergy or bore at isn't
mocking titanium.
He's just an innocent fool.
It's titanium that makes an ass of
herself similar to bottom,
making an ass of titanium by being an
ass g uses his own ass street to bring
out the ass in everyone around him.
Wouldn't it be more better instead of
having a vote in age,
just saying,
all right,
if you as go cubes,
you can vote.
Uh,
I,
you know,
I would be willing to try it.
And some,
a smaller way.
In an early Bruno clip,
Cohen interviews some of the coolest,
hippest and wealthiest fashion designers
at a fashion show,
one of whom has produced a line of
trailer trash fashion for the catwalk.
Yes.
Literally like Mugatunes Dera leaked
from zoo lander.
Bruno asks her about this line of
clothes and prompts the stylist pete
eight little too honest.
So 10 for Antonio Holmes says this,
watch trash trashing queer porter and
where to buy as a cloud.
I don't think they can afford it.
Cohen is of course aware that they can,
asking at an upscale fashion show at
poor people can buy the clothes on
display is stupid,
but this stupidity is just a foil to get
them to reveal what Cohen already knows.
So you can see how Cohen takes this
classical archetype of a clown taught to
him by Golly,
Aa and brought it up to date.
But besides foolishness,
the clown can also bring out people's a
less than pleasant side too,
by incorporating a racial stereotype and
nationalism or sexuality.
A clown can reveal prejudices better
than most.
So in four at sings and people sing
along,
Cohen is baiting people's prejudices by
mirroring them or when Bhorat does this,
every single man,
woman and child.
Yeah,
sure.
It's funny because we know he's being
clown,
but it's all so depressingly revealing
of public opinion during the Iraq war.
When Bruno and his partner make out and
start undressing in the middle of a cage
fight,
we see the entire crowd doing this.
But if all Cohen is doing is making an
ass of people,
what's the difference between him and an
Internet trolls?
Trolls tried to elicit a strong reaction
out of their audience.
Sure.
But they're all so hostile and negative.
The cloud,
on the other hand,
has no malicious intent.
They're just stupid.
A clown simply gives their targets,
enough rope to hang themselves with.
I didn't imply anybody here is racism
costs,
not I'm racist toward Muslims,
but even then,
whatever deeper purpose of clown has,
it should always come second to making
people laugh.
Obviously the first aim is to be as
funny as you can,
but you know,
occasionally you,
you know,
we end up uncovering some unpleasant
truths.
So why do we think of clowns only as
white makeup wearing and poorly sized
motor vehicle driving child scares.
What we picture when someone says clown
today is known as the red cloud,
which was invented as a companion to be
original white clown.
The red clown was created in the 19th
century by actors and circus performers
like Joseph Per Maldi,
Jordahl Fox and Tom belling who
obviously weren't funny enough without a
red nose.
And that's the image that's taken over
today,
whether it's used as an insult or to
scare children.
Clowns have an image problem.
A lot of that art you Scalia is because
we've forgotten what a clown actually is
and why clowns like Cohen are so
important.
A clown isn't defined by his makeup,
which has always been a muddle of
different influences anyway.
Golly,
eight once a student has discovered his
clown,
he no longer announces with his outfit.
A clown doesn't need any of that stuff.
A clown is innocent.
This is what separates a real clown from
whatever the hell this is.
A clown should be invisible.
A clown can slip amongst any group,
particularly the people who think that
they're powerful or successful.
You want to say big up yourself.
We'll trust board boot trust,
trust,
galley,
respect,
because the clown isn't seen as a
threat.
That's how clowns draw out their
qualities.
In these same people like selfishness,
foolishness,
childishness,
clumsiness and outright stupidity,
which is why someone like Cohen can get
Pat Buchanan to admit that.
Is it ever worth fighting a war over
sandwiches?
Is it ever worth fighting a war?
Um,
yes.
Or this in less than a month,
less than a month.
A first grader can become a first
Grenada
low.
Yeah.
If you're watching who is America,
you're probably cringing along with me
as Sasha tears apart.
Our current cultural nightmare these
days.
It's easier and easier to face anxiety
wherever you turn,
but luckily it's also easier than to
find help to cope with it.
So this video is sponsored by better
help.
The online counseling service.
I actually tried it myself,
spoke with a certified therapist named
Jennifer,
and she was great.
She was professional,
firmly qualified,
and was as good or better than any
therapist I've seen in real life.
My favorite things about better help our
one completely confidential too.
It removes the stigma of looking for
help and three,
it can work around your schedule.
In the GIG economy,
it's almost impossible to dedicate
yourself to a regular time slot,
but with better help you determine your
own therapy scheduled.
You can communicate with the counselor
via message,
live chat,
phone,
or video conferencing while you were in
your pool playing with your dog.
Whatever is most productive for you.
It's super important that you're able to
find a mental health professional that
works for you and with better helps,
huge network of licensed professionals.
It's easier than ever to start having
productive counseling sessions that are
convenient and accessible.
So if you're like me and you think you
could benefit from speaking to someone
on a regular basis,
checkout better.
help.com/wise
crack five or click here.
And as always,
thanks for watching guys.
Peace.